hey everyone it's mikos and this is the
orderflows market analysis for July 10
2017 this Monday um equities were pretty
much unchanged um we're off our all-time
highs and we're coming into earning
season Pepsi JP Morgan City Group Wells
Fargo and others are reporting uh this
week and also what you have this week is
uh Janet Yellen talking to uh Congress
on Wednesday it's their semiannual
monetary policy report and also tomorrow
on Tuesday you got Leo brard um giving a
speech
basically talking about the
normalization of central bank balance
sheets um crude oil was up about a half
a perc S&P is pretty much uh unchanged
there are some uh decent numbers coming
out later in the week but I think it's
just a slow beginning and we're waiting
to see while earnings come out so first
a brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or making any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor investing could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading only those with sufficient risk
Capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results now the
tools I use in this presentation are the
overflows Trader volume footprint chart
and the Delta scalper um let's just uh
let's jump into it first uh I said you
know it was kind of a quiet day not a
whole heck of a lot uh really to talk
about but there was there was still some
you I'll say interesting things there
are still some trading opportunities I
think in uh some of these markets so you
know we'll start with the uh interest
rates
and this is the five years you again you
know we had our high around just before
700 in the morning started selling off
boom boom boom get down here to the
swing low start rallying back up you got
these two zero prints in there Market's
moving pretty quick and well when I say
Market's moving pretty quick what I'm
talking about is got some very
aggressive buying happening very quick
when you see Zero prints like that treat
them you know as as gaps right and you
know treat them trade them the way you
would trade a a normal Gap you also have
the Delta scalper kicking off so you
know the market is shifting from a
demand sorry a supply driven Market to
aggressive buying a demand driven Market
coming in and you know if you're Gap you
know if if you understand how to trade
gaps you know look for a pullback into
that Gap as a buying opportunity so you
got Delta scalper giving you a sign
there and you have what I consider a Gap
in the bar right here and what happens
in the next bar you pop up then after
that you come right down fill that Gap
and then you rally rally up to new highs
so this was a decent trading opportunity
you can have very very low risk you know
you could be buying it right in here so
you know you got a bullish signal you
know you got a gap in here look for a
pull back to that Gap and for a move
back up now where's the move going to
stop I don't know okay but I'm telling
you you got a low risk buying
opportunity there manage your trade from
here you see you got a big selling
imbalance there that's that's obviously
not a good sign um you know if you're
managing your trade um before it sold
off here but this was a nice buying
opportunity the next one is in the bonds
um interesting thing in the in the order
flow is so what I call this double
bottom kind of this double bottom well
it's not a bottom but it's a double
swing low
and it's right here so we came off from
our high we had the Divergence no ratio
no ratio in the next bar in fact it's a
bullish ratio Delta scoper given a sell
but it's a green bar so you really
shouldn't be looking at taking it even
though eventually it did work I don't
like taking cells on green bars but you
come down here to the swing low this is
the price rejector given a buy you got a
bullish ratio and then you hit that low
again a second time and you got less
volume and to me it's always always a
key you know when every time you test a
low or a high whether it's a swing high
or swing low watch the volume it's going
to be very telling you know a lot of
people leave out volume in their
analysis but that's a big mistake
and what it's telling you is there's
less interest down here even if you're
just looking at this bar compared to
this bar the bar with the 1098 versus
the bar with 44.6 everything is just
like a shade less you know almost half
less you know 24 892 439 962 290 even on
the offer side you know 6 uh 1137 versus
668 493 against 267 so on the second
time you come down to test that low
there's less trading there's less volume
going through so you know Traders aren't
interested at these price levels anymore
you know you have almost less than half
of the activity that you had on the
first bar and that's a very bullish sign
in this case cuz it's a double bottom
you that's a very telling sign of what
can happen to this Market it's telling
you it's coming down back to this low
but there's less activity occurring down
there and what happens is the market
turns around and we rally rally up to
the swing high with this ratio up here
and then we sell off again
now the next market I'll talk about is
NASDAQ
um give me a sec get the NASDAQ chart up
and again I'm just going to talk about
one thing on this chart Delta scalper
you NASDAQ is was all over the place
today it was nice com in a nice
contracted trade um you know just take
it from the cash open you know honestly
from the cash open NASDAQ mini Dow
that's that's the time you should be
looking to trade it you know really
quick though again um you know if you're
on my I gave a webinar on Friday with
investor inspiration it's probably it's
it's up on YouTube I believe um I'll try
and get a link to it and get it out to
people but you know one of the things I
talked about in there was these um swing
lows or lows of the day or highs of low
highs of the days and swing highs where
you get point of control right at the
extreme very bullish and here you got it
happening right on your low of the days
at 8:08 in the morning look at that boom
you got a bullish ratio you got people
stuck in the market 265 you got big sell
and imbalance down there and what
happens is is the market just freaking
rallies right off of that but again um
you know that happened just before cash
opened and you know for me I I
personally I I prefer to trade uh you
know these I'll say these smaller
indices but things like uh mini da and
NASDAQ during the cast session S&P is
fine you could trade it before the cash
session um there decent volume but you
know even if you just look here you the
volume is just lesser but you know I I
know people that like to trade is
starting at seven um again it's a
personal choice I I just find that the
signals to be trer um when you got more
liquidity but anyway I'm just going to
look at Delta scalper here this morning
this is um NQ so you know okay 8:30
right on the cash open you get a sell
there but you you got to be very quick
it sells off right down to the low of
the day where you had that uh point of
control right on the bottom rallies back
up Delta scop and gives a sell this one
doesn't work
out nothing there nothing
there nothing there then boom we get the
swing High Delta scoper give us a sell
there it's a nice move lower lower
lower Delta scoper buy but it's a red
candle don't take buys on red candles
the Market's still going lower you know
if anything you should be fading those
you know you get a a buy a blue get a a
Buy Signal on a red candle get short it
it's
why is
because what you're seeing in the bar
changed really late in the bar that's
why I'm not advising in it you know you
what you're getting is you know it's
reading Delta it's not reading price
okay that's why when we created this the
indicator the tool um we didn't take
price into account or Price action of
the bar rather we just Tak in pure Delta
um but you know so to be getting long on
a bar that can't close higher than where
it opened is not a good sign and and
it's telling you that laid in the bar
that you know selling came in and you
know reason it has a positive Delta is
cuz it was done early there was decent
volume um traded in the bar early on the
offer side that's causing the positive
Delta but for whatever reason in the bar
things changed and selling came in and
came in very fast the bar closed out and
you made um you know you closed lower
and you often will keep going lower
so um any more signals here no no no
it's only 9 o' here on this chart it's a
eight range
chart I'm just looking just looking for
the the Delta scalpers on here is is you
someone messaged me saying it it was
great today so I want to show you guys
here here just off the high you got to
sell then you sold off hit the swing
lows a Buy Signal rallied up
hit this High here um we got a sell just
went sideways though before it rallied
made a new
high then swing low
here gives a buy and you just you know
you just shoot straight up here this is
uh
5698 gosh where we we went all the way
up here to uh 50 you above
um 5711 rather so you
know anyway uh then we sold off this
it's selling IM balance then we closed
for the day so again you I showed that
chart cuz someone messaged me saying hey
it was it was really great today on the
uh on the
NASDAQ um what are the markets I look at
okay just really quick this is the Delta
scalper on the the euro currency chart
he had one sell
here it go down yeah a little bit this
one is it's a sell but it's on a green
candle I'm not interested and you got to
buy on a red candle so not much in the
Euro Curr it's kind of a quiet day in
the euro currency most of the morning
okay uh we'll look at the uh e- minis
this is the four
range so here's Cash open we got the low
um nothing it's kind of just goes
sideways you just sort of hangs around
the opening not the um yeah the opening
price this yellow line it's actually
orange but it looks yellow is the
opening price and you know every time I
see the market just sort of hang around
that opening price you know especially
after the cash opens just tell me at
that time there's just not much interest
in the market we're just hanging around
I would say unchanged but you know it's
it's Sunday night when it reopens and
we're just hanging around that price
coming into the day session uh or sorry
the cash session is is not a great sign
at that moment really what you want to
look for is you know a solid move away
in either direction either to the upside
or to the downside even here you got the
Delta scalper giving you a sell it's
just right above that opening price and
yeah it sells off over the next bar but
then it rallies right back up
you here you get a Delta scaler given a
cell and again you know it it sells off
like three ticks then you get a Delta
scalper given a buy again you know I'd
rather be looking for moves away from
you know an area of congestion rather
than a move back into an area of
congestion and this one you know is a
better move right so you got two moves
here you got to sell you got to
buy which would you rather take you know
and again you know at this point where
was I I don't remember what the volume
profile looked like
but you know I can imagine at this time
your value area is probably somewhere up
in here value area high somewhere here
and again you know what would you rather
take would you rather take a move back
into your value area or move away from
the value area it's going to you got
more personally I think you got more um
profit potential on a move away from
value area because what the market can
do is it's going to look for a new value
area rather than you know when you start
trading back in into your value area
yeah you can get a move to the other
side of the value area but chances are
you're just going to rotate around value
so even though this one this Buy Signal
is a little bit lower you know like
Point lower I think this one's got more
potential than a move back into your
value area and rotating around value I'd
really rather look for the move away
from value and you get it here you know
it rallies up towards the high comes off
go sideways eventually hits the high
again and later makes a new high now you
got a new high up here you got the Delta
scalper giving a sell and it's coming to
the cash close already it's around 250
um you know take it for what you will um
you know I don't like to play around the
cash close
but you know if you took this one yeah
it was a nice one a little you know
lower but you honestly i' personally I'd
just rather stay away from the cash
close okay just really quick this is the
e- mini 10 range chart and you know you
had a ratio Divergence here it didn't
sell off it just went a little bit lower
but you again it's it's one of those
things is very interesting this this uh
this High here this bar this previous
bar closed at
11:05 and this bar here at this High
closed at 2117 so he went from 11 to 12
12: 1 1 to 2 3 hours traded 170,000
contracts over 170,000
and you know you're stuck in a bar it's
a 10 range chart if you're looking at
you know a f minute chart I think I got
a f minute chart here it's just a normal
um a normal bar chart but you know if
you're looking at a normal bar chart
here and you're literally you're trading
you know here to here and there's
there's nothing there's no signs of
anything you know that's why I prefer a
range chart you know because you just
spent three hours trading in basically a
twoo range Two and a Half Point range
you even though you got a signal you do
get a rati Divergence next bar you
finally come out of it and it just
rallies back up really quick make that
new High when the bar after you've been
in a bar for a long time and a bar comes
right back opposite direction it's
usually got a little bit more to that
move to go um you do make that new high
and then you sell off here so you know
this was an interesting High you know I
said it took a long time for this bar to
form it took 3
hours and the volume is very heavy and I
said you got out of it pushed a little
bit lower then came right back really
quick which is a sign to me that the
market can go a little bit higher um you
know we got about a point higher before
we sold
off okay so thanks for watching this
presentation um to learn more about the
trading software Us in this presentation
and how you can profit from orderflow
Vis my website orderflows
docomo go to Deltas scaler.com so thanks
and you know I didn't talk about crude
honestly there's there's I didn't really
see see much happening in the crude
today you know screw it I'll show you
the chart really quick um you know crude
going back to you know know 5:00 yeah
yeah the Delta scoper gave a sell there
the market sold off um so low here
nothing no reason no reason down here in
the order flow just you know Market is
at this point just doing what it's
supposed to do it's just
trading you know your your normal
numbers Delta scoper gave a sell here
did
kind of go nowhere before it sold
off rallies
up you know no no clear signs
necessarily in the orderflow this
morning
you there were some more Advanced
Techniques but I don't want to get into
that right now um it says it's just kind
of a quiet morning you come back up here
to your high nothing on this high is in
terms of the orderflow there's this 420
got some heavy volume up here um with
this that's why you got that strong
Delta um doesn't really come off just
goes sideways rallies back up here you
got Divergence then the market sells off
and you know just really picks up
accelerates here on the selling
17800 um some strong numbers 400 400 and
a
th000 before you sort of hit your your
swing low then it starts building up
again strong positive deltas and you
just go
sideways till the close so not much not
much in the crude this morning to really
get excited about so anyway guys you
know I'll end it for now and thanks for
watching this and I hope to have the
room back up the trading room back up
should be up on Tuesday had some issues
with the uh trading host but hopefully I
think it got it solved so thanks
everyone bye-bye